april zu kaufen meine lieben freunde ich
weiß nicht so ganz ob das was ich in
diesem video machen werde so schlau ist
allerdings kaufen wir heute das teuerste
produkt bei apple
hier sind wir auch schon auf der website
von apple wie die haben das tausendste
neue macbook pro rausgebracht für kaufte
apple neues produkt und zack gibt es
wieder ein neues macbook pro haben sie
hier auf jeden fall die haben auch ein
macbook air mit der power des
m2m bmw m 2 ist aber erst ab juli
erhältlich von einer gehen wir auch hier
weiter von 13 das verstehe ich nicht
riesen kampagne hier zumindest in
hamburg habe ich halt gesehen gemacht
mit dieser grünen iphone
es kann ja nichts mehr dass sie einfach
nur hässlich ja jetzt geworden aber gut
okay geben wir hier weiter ein von 13
sowas von quad core i7 quad fitnessplus
ipad eher airports die airports kostet
serienproduktion
weiß ich aus einer quelle von einem
apple-mitarbeiter unter zehn euro
und die verkauften die dinger für 190
aber ich weiß wen ich würde kostenlose
gravur wir haben heute allerdings die
mission das teuerste apple produkt zu
kaufen von der emotionen erstmal die
kategorien das jetzt glaube ich so unser
unsere einkaufstasche einkaufstaschen
die wirklich ordentlich gefüllt dann
haben wir oben noch die suche da können
wir logischerweise sehen welche sachen
suchen wir haben noch den support knopf
zubehör bei zubehör wird es nicht dabei
sein bei zubehör ist ja nicht so dass
gehört auch mit dazu tv und haben das
könnte was seien jedoch nicht
die zum teil aus ohne dass andere
haben ihr apple tv auf vier karat hd
support mini das ist glaube ich auch
alles nicht sooo airports werden dann
denke ich auch nicht fündig weil die ja
schon 199 eur 279 euro airports mir okay
612 euro das teuerste produkt das wir
gesehen haben ihm allerdings mal rüber
zur lodge da weiß ich auf jeden fall das
wirklich jetzt einfach auf die watchlist
apple nicht und das wird die neueste
sein wenn ich hier so steht die kannst
du auf jeden fall mit gold nehmen und
dann sollte schon teuer sein also die
klicken mal auf welche nehmerländern
[Musik]
wir sind am ende
das heißt die teuerste sind diese ms
4000 das ist auch nicht so toll oder ein
gehen wir mal rüber zum iphone das
kostet allerdings dass noch was ist das
neueste iphone 3 cent pro wenn wir dann
hier auf kaufen klicken und nehmen das
teuerste also das große in graphit mit
einem terabyte
nee ich habe keine iphone zum
eintauschen und dann 1800 ist jetzt auch
nicht klar es ist viel aber wir brauchen
mehr bei einer kreditkarte in
verfügungsrahmen von 25.000 euro
also let's go wir hier oben mal rüber
zum ipad da haben wir das neueste ipad
mit dem apple in 1 chip was sie wirklich
können guck mal das ist wirklich
marketing durch scrolls über die website
wie geil das alles aussieht du denkst
halt wirklich du kaufst den besseres
leben dadurch dass sie ein produkt von
denen kauft sie kriegen auf kaufen meine
lieben freunde und schauen mal was das
teuerste ipad ist 1000 oder
mein macbook war teurer von sagen wir
mal rüber zu den macbooks ich hab das 16
zoll macbook pro ich kann mal ganz kurz
gucken wie teuer das war das war die
grösste ausstattung nämlich war ich
arbeite halten damit die schneider mit
videos mit damit unterwegs ich brauche
diese ganzen sachen ich weiß ja nicht
was ziel der genommen unterschied das
aber mag rein
final cut schneide ich ihn mit logic pro
ich kann noch kein klavier spielen wir
sind bei
dir sind wir sind bei fast schon 10.000
euro okay ich las die seite mal offen wo
stimmt gehen gibt's ja das ist diese
parmesan käse reiben ja
absolut beschissen wir kriegen einfach
mal auf kaufen mal gucken was hat an den
ok wir sind selbst jetzt schon mal 7000
wir stießen wir seitdem ja ganz kurz und
konfigurieren und ein mac ich bin
gespannt micro anpassen wir haben 3,5
ghz 8 core interessieren wie prozessor
turbo boost bis 4,0 gigahertz die
könnten noch irgendwo dazwischen ultra
packen und ich würde nicht wissen dass
das nicht stimmt turbo boost
[Musik]
grafikspeicher
speicher das ist der letzte zwischen
grafikspeicher und speicher 6 max
hat mir schon von daher schauen wir mal
was wir hier so machen können ein tausch
gerät hinzufügen ich arbeite mit einem
windows-pc ach gottchen
anstatt eines 35 herz 8 core intel xeon
prozessor mit einem turbo boost bis zu
4,4 geld können wir auch gehen auf 1 2
das ist doch weniger achso 2,5 ghz
28 cordes 20 kurz mehr intel xeon
prozessors
natürlich machen wir das wähle den 24 28
kontaktieren prozessor wenn du auf
deinem mac pro in ihm einen
arbeitsspeicher von 15 terabyte wird
natürlich
ich brauche den arbeitsspeicher von 15
terabyte weil ich arbeite mit speicher
scrollen aber weiter runter wir können
den arbeitsspeicher
hey leute ich
muss gleich meine bank anrufen ihre
afrique unterstützt welche grafikkarte
ist die richtige für dich
ich nehme alle von da her kicken war
auch hier unten auf die teuerste das ist
nämlich die 13.000 zwei radeon provet
69 00 mit je 32 gigabyte gb
ddr
sechster kompakt also weiter geht's der
speicherplatz wie viel speicherplatz
brauchen wir denn was sagten dass ist
miranda texte nehmen natürlich das
größte 8 terabyte ssd speicher
ich schneide der videos hier selber mit
deswegen wollen wir natürlich auch die
after burner karte und natürlich auch
magic trackpad magic mouse & magic
trackpad dass sie nicht mal wenn ich so
ein ding 62 k kaufen das sie mir dann
nicht mal eine maus kostenlos geben die
vig so ja klar wir nehmen natürlich auch
das nano texturen glas das brauchen wir
den prozent für prost and cost immer
noch 1000 euro
ich hab das war ja damals dieses nimmt
dass apple diese das ist einfach das ist
sich das vorstellt ist ein stativ
das ist so ständer für den monitor der
monitor an sich kostet 6 k
aber das zu dem monitor überhaupt
erstmal hinstellen kann es kostet
nochmal einen kam wir fügen das alles
hier hinzu und selbstverständlich
brauchen wir noch apple care plus apple
care plus fürs display und dreist under
bolt kabel
ich habe problem herzlich willkommen bei
der hamburger volksbank ich musste mich
mal ganz kurz weil ich nicht weiß ob
diese musik gegen die copyright
geschützt dass bald sie aziz extrem
scheiße hier habe ich jetzt zehn minuten
mit einem volksbank berater über
überweisung slam mit unbefristete
mietverträge und habe zu erinnert die
scheiße gesprochen war super interessant
wir haben probleme
ich kann das nur ändern wenn ich einen
antrag stelle also dann geht es entweder
unbefristet oder befristet keine ahnung
was bei der verfügungsrahmen ist maximal
25.000 was man selber irgendwie in
seinem online banking service krams
modul da im internet einstellen kann
ich mir auch schon vorher denken können
also meine damen und herren moral von
der geschicht ich habe mir diesen mac
pro hier zusammengestellt mit diesem
ganzen sachen drin
ist auf jeden fall ist extrem teuer dann
hab ich natürlich selbst verstehe oder
das produkt sehr nahe und texturen glas
mit dazu genommen den posten im visa und
adapter volt kabel und alle möglichen
anderen adaptern die man auch noch so
benötigt einfach eine ganz normale
bestellung bei apple für schlussendlich
75.000 40 euro nach 78 cent wenn ich
jetzt bestelle ist das ding erst versand
fähig in sechs bis acht wochen werde ich
auch gar nicht mehr in hamburg sondern
schon wieder in köln
+ ich kann es jetzt gerade noch nicht
kaufen weil ich diese antrag bei einer
volksbank stellen muss ist mir auf jeden
fall jetzt ein zu großer stress und ich
bin auch ganz ehrlich ich dachte nicht
dass wir jetzt auf 75 kam ich dann
vielleicht irgend so ein ding für
12.000 allerhöchstens oder so und dann
bestelle ich das im test war das aber
dann sah irgendwie apple jetzt gern
zurückgeben hat in der rückgabe umtausch
von vier wochen oder sollten kranz ist
auch egal sein leider nicht geklappt
aber wir wissen jetzt dass das deutsche
brot von apple fast 100 k kostet
ich bevor ich habe das video gefallen
und das fazit ist jetzt dass apple
wirklich sehr teuer ist